slow down Rob mobs are out and they are
beautiful soak it in Mary it's so cool
you can do with some of these latest
mods that have been popping out that's
right and this one is nice fly by
Ciolino it lets you basically just jump
into the sky and soar like an eagle it
is exactly that what's interesting is
that he calls a nice fly but he also
calls it hancock mode all right as it
Will Smith so let's give it a shot
Oh
recovery from damage Austin your methods
are too wily you're crazy you're gonna
get someone killed
yeah all right no impact all right cool
why don't you gracefully land okay over
there by some people can I mean that
beautiful telekinesis by Dave a 94 yeah
so let's give it a shot here Oh what was
that that's a lady ring who cares liquor
and I can slammer oh yes
citizen where is your Congress take me
to meet you later I was a good one
you knew him time to answer she's just
dead lady other night she looks like an
alien herself oh no she's going to
college
Trevor's magic bat spy bug bug bug butts
oh there's the magic I should be able
there's also moves we're gonna throw
them in directions so see here whoa
shoot that guy he's all telekinetic and
[__] just make him go away just push him
as far as you can go goodbye now Mary
okay
you got another one here another weapon
uh this one is called
the nuke railgun a reason being so merry
this is great so I don't you know this
is that when you get five stars in
unmounted GTA you never get tanks you
just get like fbi's and helicopters so
this one is five star army which is
awesome so now you get tanks
I thought I was saving and you get hind
helicopters pickup me on me maybe even
have a shot I didn't like it when you
did that
I guess now I owe what a meta game
remember me [__] so I'm using the
controller flying just leave me the
butter oh no I don't have any [__] [__]
is right here the way Santa Claus bye
Santa
interior locations all the ones from the
game mm-hmm
ones that you were never able to get
into before well you only like they're
related to the story mission and then
you couldn't really access it so chicken
factory
chicken factory yes this is no place for
a street performer no they're getting
deep-fried any fry can you get in there
whoa
this is your nightmare freedom
[Music]
worst dream ever
whoa
all right let's go somewhere else let's
go somewhere else
Mary I call up all your friends hey guys
you know the spot my yeah yeah the whole
pen bring the whole pen oh you are a
party animal oh how do you twist
oh here's the problem right now we have
telekinesis still on so any person that
comes is going not gonna be having a
great time
fart it up you girls ready to get dirty
yeah can you climb those stairs I'm
coming I'm coming
get out of my way mud bath get away yeah
problems and they're all hose oh oh oh
hey what'd I miss this party's just
getting started
Oh Oh we got chips no problem I got this
[Laughter]
[Music]
and for the finale we're gonna [__]
Jesus anyways I was was Jesus doesn't
need to walk on water anymore this is
like California because of the drought
[Applause]
[Music]
cool yeah we get it
Oh sharks are spawning they're spawning
near you land you rely on that Hancock
mode too much seriously not cool oh my
god and he realized I'm not lying too
much on it no Jesus California needs
more water we're in a drought when we
come back Jesus will bring water
previously on Jesus California is losing
water Jesus comes down finally from
heaven to give California the water it
deserves but he went too far
oh my god all right I'm sorry guys oh no
we already kind of screwed up the world
with too much water why not just go all
the way [__] I'm coming to save you hang
on my children I just need a really cool
sub to come down and look at you know I
said summery
Oh what's happening I don't know that
the waves it's not Jesus with always
Jesus well well that was tough stuff
well until next time
oh good good stuff good stuff by Jesus I
do this
goodbye my children
you